well here to weigh in on this is Michael
Knowles the host of the Michael Nowell
show who wants to weigh in on this hey
Michael thank you for joining us what do
you think about this does the celebrity
endorsements to the celebrity opinions
do they work
nothing says Main Street American voter
like Lily Tomlin and Hanoi Jane Fonda I
think the Democrats really have their
finger on the pulse of the country you
know in 2016
1889 celebrities endorsed Hillary
Clinton that's a real number
actors athletes musicians they all
endorsed Hillary a lot of good it did
her didn't do her very much
Hollywood doesn't have a lot of
credibility right now as they're
fighting off all of the subordinates
that they've sexually assaulted they
don't have a lot of credibility
perhaps Meryl Streep will cut a campaign
ad with Harvey Weinstein her good buddy
and they can talk about the Republican
war on women probably not going to play
you mentioned reason that they're doing
this the reason that they're doing this
is because Democrats have nothing to say
do you remember those 23 celebrities who
said they'd moved to Canada if President
Trump won who said well you the sky was
going to fall the markets would implode
what do we have the economy is booming
that joblessness is at record lows
there's peace abroad Isis destroyed
militarily they have nothing to say and
when you have nothing to run on
Hollywood celebrities are a good
mouthpiece to just send it out yeah and
we can't relate to them you know most
Americans are trying to put food on
their table and living paycheck to
paycheck they can't really relate to the
celebrities in Hollywood
you mentioned athletes LeBron James he
he says that he doesn't agree with the
president he thinks the president is
using sports to divide our country
listen to us what I noticed over the
last few months that he's kind of used
sport to kind of divide us and and
that's something that I can't relate to
because I know that sport was the first
time I ever was around someone white
Michael well I have to say I sort of
support the LeBron James Democrat
candidacy because I think he's the only
candidate they have who still has a
pulse there's Bernie Sanders Hillary
Clinton Lyle Wafaa Elizabeth Warren so
he has that going for him but talking
about dividing the country who's
dividing the country the people who say
you should stand for the American flag
or the people who sit down and
disrespect the symbol of our country I
don't think that's going to work as a
campaign slogan for him in 2020 a vote
for LeBron James and disrespect the
American flag support Colin Kaepernick
probably not going to play in Peoria all
right